thanks for joining us here at 11 o'clock
i'm denise valdez around three percent
of americans are now eligible for a
third dose of the cobit 19 vaccine and
some have already gotten their shot arco
manna live to break down who can get it
and also the potential timeline for
everybody else orco
well denise if your immuno compromise
and it's been 28 days since your second
shot you can get a third everyone else
has to wait and the timeline is still
unclear for those who got the johnson
and johnson vaccine we asked an expert
why
we were glad that it was available and
we were definitely relieved to get it
larry hatab and his wife both received
their third dose of the mederna kova 19
vaccine this week their immuno
compromise making them eligible for the
shock larry says the decision was easy
to make we just
figured the more protection the better
because we both have to be very careful
for everyone else u.s health officials
recommend the extra dose be administered
8 months after getting the second shot
of the pfizer or moderna vaccine
infectious disease epidemiologist brian
labis tells me that's the ideal time
because it's late enough to get lasting
immunity but early enough to prevent
covet complications we study the the
antibody levels in people we look and
see how those decline over time we also
look at increased risk of infection or
serious disease but why have no
recommendations been made for an extra
dose of the johnson johnson vaccine we
started using the johnson johnson
vaccine later so we don't have as much
data on the long-term effects of that
vaccine on the bodies some people are
skeptical about getting an extra dose i
believe in good health and i
am not interested in having to continue
to take
a booster shot but larry says it's for
the greater good it's not just your own
protection it's protecting other people
now the third dose of the pfizer and
moderna vaccine should be available to
the general public starting the week of
september 20th assuming the fda and cdc
sign off on it reporting live near the
las vegas strip tonight orco mana 8 news
now